[Musica]
[Applauso]
quando gli organizzatori del tedex
invitato qui
Quest'oggi sono rimasto un po' perplesso
perché mi hanno detto che avrei dovuto
imparare un discorso a memoria di 15-1
minuti e il problema è che io la memoria
non ce l'ho e quindi la prima cosa che
ho chiesto è stata proprio penso me lo
possano confermare ma si possono usare
le slide quando mi è stato detto sì
Allora ho detto accetto volentieri
altrimenti per me sarebbe stato
impossibile essere qui infatti io ero il
peggiore studente delle elementari delle
medie del liceo e dell'università e
ricordo benissimo quando in terza media
nel 1999 la mia professoressa di
italiano mi chiamò al banco per
interrogarmi però fu una giornata
particolare perché non solo chiamo me al
banco ma chiese a mia madre che tra
l'altro qui in sala ve lo può
testimoniare di venire in classe al
posto mio e di vedere l'interrogazione
perché lei era certa che io non avessi
studiato e allo stesso tempo mia madre
era certa che io avessi studiato perché
tutti i giorni andavo a fare doposcuola
quindi si sedeta al mio banco io andrai
andrai tremando come una foglia ricordo
benissimo quella giornata e quando mi
interrogò feci praticamente scena muta
provavo a rispondere però era talmente
agitato che che venne veramente
difficile e da quel momento io ho avuto
un odio verso il sistema scolastico
pazzesco È stato un una una continua
lotta contro l'autorità e questo mi ha
portato negli anni ad essere poi
bocciato al liceo classico perché non
sapevo studiare in più odiavo tutto
quello che facevo e quindi voi non voi
questo è stato l'epilogo io in realtà
quando dico non sapevo studiare non è
che non sapevo studiare il problema
avevo una gravissima mancanza di Focus e
di concentrazione Infatti io Ad oggi
ancora non riesco a leggere libri Se io
provo a leggere una pagina di un libro
mi perdo e quindi ho cercato sempre di
trovare delle strategie che mi
permettessero di fare meglio e infatti
poi ho scoperto gli audiolibri e da
quando ho scoperto gli audiolibri ne
leggo più di uno al giorno perché riesco
ad ascoltare a
3.5x questa è stata una delle frasi che
mi hanno sempre ripetuto tutta la vita e
CH mi conosce Qui ce ne sono tanti che
mi conoscono lo sanno Non ce la farei
mai perché purtroppo quando tu
identifichi una persona diversa dalle
altre la frase che ti viene sempre in
mente non ce la farà mai e Mi sono
sempre sentito una pecora nera in mezzo
a un gruppo di pecore bianche fino a
quando poi ho capito che in realtà tu
sei una pecora nera finché vivi in
quell'ambiente quando fai un passetto
indietro un passetto di lato
quell'ambiente ti fa diventare una
persona diversa e io non ero più la
pecora nera in mezzo alle pecore bianche
ma ero una pecora felice che Sal
alterava in giro non tutti siamo uguali
non mi stancherò mai di dirlo
e io di difficoltà ne ho avute e
purtroppo nel 2004 le mie difficoltà
sono continuate e infatti ricordo
benissimo quando tutti i giorni andavo a
fare un esame chiamavo mia mamma mio
papà e continuo a dirgli Oggi ho un
altro esame e poi quando li chiamavo per
dirgli com era andato l'esame continuavo
a dire Sono stato bocciato sono stato
bocciato a 24 esami per il primo anno di
università in realtà gli esami sono otto
Ma io continuavo a farli ne studiavo uno
mi bocciava tempo Siccome io ho un po'
la fomo la paura di perdere le
opportunità Ne studiavo un altro e
quindi andavo a prepararmi preparato due
esami e mi bocciano tutti e due e così
via fino a dicembre io quindi da
settembre 2004 e vedo Antonio che
sorride e me lo può confermare anche lui
questa cosa qui feci tutte le sessioni
possibili e mi ricordo benissimo che io
barav un po' è brutto da dire però in
realtà io volevo superare gli esami davo
sempre la colpa a qualcun altro non era
mai la colpa mia E dicevo No ma non sono
io sono i professori che non mi fanno
passare gli esami e allora cambia il mio
cognome da Caiazzo Mi registravo gli
esami con gaiazzo di modo che potessi
iscrivermi alle alle altre sessioni e il
risultato ovviamente non cambiava mi
continuavano a bocciare il primo anno
feci Zero esami io studiavo ve lo
assicuro come andavo al a ripetizione
durante il il liceo anche durante
l'università studiavo E chi e chi era
con me poteva può testimoniarlo a quel
punto io avevo due opzioni o
mollavo oppure imparavo un metodo che
non era ad oggi il mio e quindi siccome
per me mollare non è un'opzione e oggi
abbiamo visto altri esempi
bellissimi ho deciso di incominciare a
fare delle interviste a tutti i miei
migliori amici e quando inizia a fare
queste interviste una una delle cose che
mi Mi arrivò Subito fu che io non avevo
un metodo Il problema è che quando non è
un metodo tu fai delle cose e pensi di
farle bene ma se non è un metodo perché
poi il sistema scolastico purtroppo non
ti insegna un metodo no ti dice studia
Quindi o tu impari a studiare per i
fatti tuoi oppure ha un problema e
Questa fu una frase che mi sconvolse
completamente la vita mi fece capire
completamente che stavo sbagliando tutto
e infatti mi dissero per far bene Devi
imitare Chi è meglio di te quindi
Copialo pure però cerca di migliorarlo e
io Faci così dopo quelle interviste
incominciai a creare il mio metodo e
quando creai il mio
metodo a dicembre del 2005 feci otto
esami tutti gli esami del primo anno in
un mese E vi assicuro che è stato
possibile proprio perché me li portavo
mi bocciava al primo portavo il secondo
mi bocciano al secondo me ne portavo tre
e quando iniziai a a studiare incominciò
a salire l'ANSA Anzi la prestazione
incominciò soffire di insonnia E sebbene
l'insonnia è una grave malattia quindi
comunque danneggia tantissimo le persone
io cercai di sfruttarla a mio vantaggio
e infatti io vivevo dalle 4:00 di
mattina alle 400 di pomeriggio e in quel
in quelle 12 ore io studiavo studiavo
con il mio nuovo metodo e questo metodo
mi permise di fare una una materia che è
una delle più difficili di tutte
Procedura Civile chei Ha fatto
Giurisprudenza lo sa benissimo In sole
due
settimane e in più qui c'è Antonio che
lo può testimoniare Grazie a questo
metodo riuscivo a far passare ai miei
amici gli esami in una singola notte che
sembra una follia ma con un metodo
applicato questa cosa era fattibile e
ricordo che non solo Antonio ma c'era
anche Cosimo Francesco Valeria c'era
tanta gente con me che faceva che usava
questa mia tecnica e in una notte
passavano gli esami Ho applicato questo
metodo a tutto nella mia vita e grazie a
questo metodo sono riuscito ad applicare
uno schema alla mia vita e qualsiasi
cosa la faccio la faccio con uno schema
Ed è proprio per questo che ho chiesto
le slide perché questa slide per me
sarebbe È stato impossibile ce l'avete
presente il cubo di Rubik no quel cubo a
sei facce che devi girare per per fare
le facce uguali il cubo di Rubik è una
cosa impossibile se non è uno schema io
ho creato il mio schema e ora riesco a
risolverlo in 30 secondi mazzo di carte
io riesco a ricordarmi 52 carte
rovesciate quindi le guardo una volta e
mi ricordo tutte le 52 carte non perché
ho memoria io non ho memoria ho una
tecnica LinkedIn Probabilmente qualcuno
di voi mi ha visto già su LinkedIn io
sono diventato la persona più ascoltata
su LinkedIn Italia con oltre 140 milioni
di visualizzazioni solo ed
esclusivamente grazie a una strategia e
alla
Costanza e in più sono riuscito ad
imparare tutte le date del calendario a
memoria Ovviamente non è memoria c'è c'è
un trucco anche lì e grazie Quando voi
mi dite una data qualsiasi ad esempio il
4 aprile 2020 Io so che in questo caso è
un sabato e voi Mi direte eh l'hai
scritto tu Grazie e io vi dico che non
mi dovete credere perché poi le cose
vanno dimostrate sempre comunque e
quindi voglio dimostrarvelo oggi e vi
chiedo una una cosa semplicissima se io
vi dicessi vi faccio memorizzare 5 mesi
del calendario a memoria in 2 minuti
forse meno di 2 minuti mi Credereste e
quanti di voi pensano di essere in grado
di ricordarsi il calendario a memoria
almeno 5 mesi facciamo il contrario
Quanti di voi invece pensano di non
essere in grado di
ricordarsi tutti che bello ora una
grande responsabilità allora io Vi
chiederò di ricordarvi questi
semplicissimi numeri 44 66 88 10 10 12
12 Allora sì è un errore del della regia
4-4 Ok 4-4 per me è il 4 aprile ci siamo
Il 66 Aiutatemi è il
6 bravissimi
88 agosto
1010 perfetto 12 12 no è il mio
compleanno quindi ricordatevelo questo
12 dicembre giustissimo Allora se io vi
dicessi che tutti questi giorni sono
sabato io vi avrei dato la chiave di
volta per imparare 5 mesi del calendario
a memoria e qualcuno magari mi dice no
non ho capito Aspetta Spiegami meglio ve
lo spiego Se il 4-4 è sabato il 54 Che
cos'è avete la chiave di per per sapere
a memoria in 5 mesi del calendario Che
giorno è ve lo ridim mostro 14-12 che
giorno è
lunedì bravissimi e quindi tutti voi
avevate alzato la mano No perché Perché
nella vostra mente c'è una credenza di
non essere in grado di imparare le cose
a memoria ma io vi dico che la memoria
non è uno strumento da utilizzare la
memoria Purtroppo è uno strumento da
utizzare a breve termine quindi se voi
imparate una strategia una tecnica per
qualsiasi cosa riuscirete ad emergere in
qualsiasi aspetto della vostra vita
grazie a questa tecnica ho finito gli
esami del quinquennio 5 anni in 2 anni 2
anni nella una delle facoltà più
difficili d'Italia perché mi sono
lavorato alla Sapienza e da essere il
peggiore studente dell'università
diventai il primo sono stato il primo
laureato Su 2000 persone e Se pensate
che il primo anno non ho fatto esami
fate un po' di conti Però c'è un
problema e qui la mia vita è sempre
fatta di alti e bassi No sono ricascato
mi sono arrivato con 100 che qualcuno
diceva Vabbè 100 Mica è male no però
purtroppo non è sufficiente perché
volevo entrare in degli studi legali e
in questi studi legali se non sei
perfetto Non puoi entrare nessuno mi
garantivo neanche un colloquio con
quegli studi dove volevo entrare io
perché Perché volevano il 110 non gli
interessava che io mi fossi lavato un
anno e mezzo prima del previsto non gli
interessava che fossi stato il primo
laureato del mio corso di laurea non gli
interessava che a 23 anni parlavo
inglese spagnolo italiano e francese e
non G interessava che avessi studiato a
Washington in Canada e avessi lavorato
sia a Washington che in Spagna non
interessava nessuno nessuno mi diede una
possibilità e quando iniziai a cercare
lavoro la risposta era sempre la stessa
non sei perfetto Non Non ebbi altre
alternative che trovare quello
che quelli che mi volevano e gli unici
che mi fecero un'offerta Fu uno stage in
una multinazionale italiana fortissima a
€250 E sebbene io fino ad allora non non
ero appassionato di soldi non avevo
proprio necessità di soldi perché mi mi
genitori sono comunque benestanti non ho
mai avuto necessità di qualcosa per un
anno ho potuto mangiare solo kebab
perché perché non avevo il coraggio di
dire ai miei genitori che l'unico lavoro
che mi ero potuto permettere era €250
dopo che loro mi avevano pagato tutta
l'università e tutto il resto e quindi
iniziai la mia rincorsa verso il denaro
che purtroppo detta così magari sembra
brutta però in realtà era una necessità
perché io comunque avevo studiato
pensavo di essere anche bravo avevo
fatto tanto nella mia vita e quindi ho
detto perché non devo voler di più E
iniziai a cercare sempre nuovi lavori No
nel dal 2009 a €250 passai dal 2011 a
1250 per me mi sembrava un'infinità però
purtroppo quella voglia non non si
smorzo nel 2013 arrivai a prendere €2500
nel 2015 3005 e nel 2016 diventai A 29
anni il capo dell'ufficio legale di una
multinazionale americana questa
multinazionale americana mi inserì in un
programma di talenti e nel 2017 mi fece
responsabile del gdpr perché non lo
sapesse un regolamento sulla privacy per
implementarlo su 38 Nazioni quindi ero
arrivato veramente ai vertici di
un'azienda americana e nel
2018 di nuovo sono stato licenziato e ho
incominciato a percepire di nuovo la
disoccupazione per Cu ho fatto domanda
della della naspi e prendevo nel 2019 di
€800 e quindi questa mia vita di nuovo
dall'alto al basso dall'alto al basso Mi
ha detto Ok forse è il caso di iniziare
a investire su me stesso e non aspettare
che sia qualcun altro di investire su di
me e lanciai una startup lanciai una
startup finanziata con i soldi che avevo
fatto durante l'erasmus alle Canarie
perché avevo finito gli esami quindi non
sapevo che fare e di F DJ a quel punto
iniziai a usare LinkedIn per lanciare
quella startup e incominciarono a
piovere clienti dal cielo creo il mio
metodo anche lì E questi clienti erano
clienti del calibro di BNL Lugo comunque
clienti davvero grossi Avio che fa
componenti missilistici che presi tutti
direttamente da LinkedIn e io in quel
momento ancora non percepivo uno
stipendio prendevo sempre quegli €800
perché la startup Sì l'ho creata prende
grandi clienti ma i clienti pagano 90
120 Comunque non è una cosa così
semplice e quindi dopo 2 anni di fatica
quando stava per scadere la naspi perché
la naspi dura 2 anni per chi non lo
sapesse riuscì a vendere la mia società
a uno dei più al più grosso gruppo
europeo in ambito software che fattura
più di 2 miliardi 8.000 dipendenti e
quindi sono passato da zero a tutto
avevo la mia macchina la macchina dei
miei sogni avevo la possibilità di
viaggiare di andare ovunque nel mondo
avevo la possibilità di vivere dove
volevo
e diventai grazie proprio a questo anche
il più ascoltato sull LinkedIn Italia
perché prima raccontavo delle cose
quando li ho iniziato a vivere è
cambiato completamente tutto Sono stato
autore Feltrinelli ho scritto un libro
con Feltrinelli col gruppo Feltrinelli
sul sul personal branding e quindi
questa cosa qui mi ha dato ancora più
visibilità sono stato su centinaia di
palchi e ho formato migliaia di persone
negli ultimi anni e ad oggi sono CEO di
cinque società in più sono un
investitore però quello che io dico
sempre è che tutto quello che sto che vi
sto dicendo non è per vantarmi ma è per
dirvi e per portare avanti un una cosa
che penso che sia super fondamentale
nella nostra vita che è quella di i voti
non definiscono la tua intelligenza
proprio per questo io assumo sempre le
persone sulla batter del proprio
carattere e non solo non mi interessano
i tuoi voti non mi interessano Quanti
anni hai Non mi interessa se hai
esperienza non mi interessa se sei
neolaureato o hai 60 anni queste cose
non le prendo in considerazione perché
le le esperienze si Acquisiscono
sul campo il tuo carattere invece è chi
sei veramente e questo lo ripeterò
sempre nulla accade per caso con il
giusto metodo e la giusta dose di
Costanza nella vita possiamo raggiungere
qualsiasi obiettivo sono stato
considerato scarso tutta la
vita questa è mia madre e il problema è
sempre il contesto non siamo mai noi e a
questo
punto se posso dirvi una cosa mi
profondo del cuore non smettete mai di
credere in voi e ora vi voglio lasciare
una frase di Albert Einstein che dice
ognuno un genio ma se si giudica un
pesce dalla sua capacità di arrampicarsi
sugli alberi passerà tutta la vita a
considerarsi uno
[Applauso]
stupido